I was wondering if uh you have like a
pre-show routine like if you like
because like sometimes I'll dance around
like I stretch a little bit before I go
on I don't it's not something I like
planned on doing but I just noticed it's
it's something that I tend to do a
lot all right I didn't know if you I
didn't know if you had anything like
that you do you said warm it up you were
around me for years you know what I do
all right what's with the [__]
question
what's happening you Savages it's
Tuesday the 12th of December the checkin
is brought to you by my favorite the
freeze pipe you need a little something
to get you through the holiday family
reunions we all do freeze pipe wants you
to smoke and save big with their holiday
sales that are running now until
Christmas this is where you got Grandma
present the neighborhood cop the
delivery guy get them all little BNS
perfect for anybody who's tired of har
smoke and coughing all the time freeze
pipe makes freezable pipes bubblers
bongs more than cool down Smoke by over
300 degrees me I love freeze pipe guys
right now I'm smoking like one of the
many bongs that they sent me and I love
it all you got to do is put the glycerin
chamber in the freezer for an hour and
when you're ready to get down pull it
out put it in take a hit of that bong
and boom nothing but icy clouds the hell
with Snoop Dog you can even keep the
glycerin chamber in the freezer the
whole time you'll never have to wait so
do yourself a favor right now you're
scratching your head what do I get this
guy what do I freeze pipe that's what
you're gonna get him so go to the freeze
pipe.com pressing code Diaz di for 10%
off your entire order who's better than
freeze pipe nobody that's right shop
holiday sales running until Christmas or
use code Diaz for 10% off atth freeze
pipe.com order today and smoke like
royalty you know what I'm saying I don't
know what the hell that means the the
line is smoked like a doctor you [__]
anyway the joint is also brought to you
by manscape listen men ladies you got to
shave that [__] Mona you want Santa
to come he can't come over and you got a
bush that looks like a [__] jungle
this isn't about looking hot for a
partner this is about giving yourself
the Christmas gift of silky SM balls
with manscape the new performance 5.0
package this [__] is a Savage
the lawm more 5.0 got the ultra the
ultra body trimmer forget about your
ball fact you can shave your eyebrows
your nose hairs the hairs in your
[__] with a fishing wire it's
tremendous it also has the weed whacker
the nose hair trimmer and the crop so
the After Shave lotion and the best one
of them all the crop preserver ball
deodorant it takes the wrinkles out of
your nut sack it looks like a baby's
elbow anyway you gotta love [__]
manscape when you get the performance
package 5.0 manscape will even throw in
two gifts a super comfortable pair of
boxes and a bag to store your goodies in
with a zipper inside I ain't saying
nothing whether you're buying it for
yourself or for someone you love for
Christmas I got a discount cofy you
ready get 20% off free shipping with
code Joey at man manc cape.com who does
that for you nobody [__] that's
20% off with free shipping at
manscape.com use code Joey manscape
wants you to have a happy holidays and
here we go for you [__] who
want to be International the year is
almost over I know you want to make uh
you know resolutions you want to learn
new language in three weeks you got to
use my people Babel that they know all
the languages those are other language
learning apps forget about it they're
just basically games that teach you
nothing Babel will get you talking to
the Mexican waiter you're talking to the
guy that throws knives at Benny forget
about
it Baba will get you learning with 10
minute lessons you'll be taught
everything you need to have to work to
be a world you know you can converse
with anybody let's say you going to a
strip club you want to learn Russian bam
there you go listen I love Babel reminds
me of my old school Spanish it's easy
it's fun and you'll look smart and what
else could you want studies even show
that you Z babo for 15 hours is just
like taking an entire semester of a
college language course so aren't you
sick and tired of the Mexican way to not
talking to you no more you want to call
them over seor that's it where you gonna
learn that Babble and here's a special
limited time deal from the checkin
listeners to get you started for the
holidays I'm going to give you 55% off
but only for checking listeners for
babel.com
joeey that's Joe y That's 55% off at
joeey spell Babel B- a BB L they're even
going to teach you how to spell Babel in
German or Romanian or something like
that so babel.com
joeey rules and restrictions May apply
Merry Christmas without further
Ado it's the
checkin Tes run for your lives it's over
they didn't put you on this planet just
to give up if Uncle joy to do it act
[__] world actually you got to be
thinking welcome back
[Music]
to it's Monday [__] Tuesday the
12 and [__] what's up my it's good to
see you dude how are you you know Tip
Top M happy Hanukkah and all this [__] I
hope you light another joint tonight I I
put the manora up I got I got joints in
that [__] this year like I told
you that's that's the play right there
anybody can light a [__] candle get a
Manor Roman candles in that [__]
and get the whole neighborhood jumping
up and down you know what I'm saying do
you have a manora that' be F I need to
get you one little baby Manor to put
joints in
there I don't want to offend nobody I
don't want to offend nobody this time of
the year you know what I'm saying it's a
it's a rough time of the year you want
to be happy
so no one's gonna get offended by a
manora [__] them that's great I gotta
dig it up I don't know what the [__] I
did with it I had that I got the Jewish
hand I got a bunch of stuff you know the
Jewish
hand how was the concert buddy the
concert
was out of this world first of all like
by Friday morning if you know anything
about me I was not looking forward to it
I was hoping
that [__] somebody bomb New York or
something like that like I was like
something's got to go down because I'm
not in the [__] mood to go over there
with 20 kids and [__] sorry about the
lights in the back my wife ain't here
tonight you know what do you want me to
do I I barely [__] uh what but you
look beautiful but here's the the thing
that was very unique like I went online
I looked at some of the bands and I
didn't know any of them you know except
for jelly roll for me it wasn't even
about the concert it was just take the
kids they wanted to go and they had been
excited and the whole [__] thing and
the girls were excited my wife and my
neighbor Crazy Chris and you know we
took two other moms and we just shot
over there on a bus man and
I was telling somebody today I got to
the garden and I sat down with my
daughter and the rest of the kids and
then the girls left to get t-shirts and
stuff but Mercy goes for a second she
goes no I'm gonna stay with Dad make
sure he's okay I was fine she just
thought you know she didn't want to go
and we were just talking and she goes
how old were you the first time you came
here and I'm like five you know and then
I was remembering the [__] circus the
first time I went to the
circus you know they give you these
whistles the these lights and on a
string and you spin them around I told
you and then the next year I went when
they turn the lights off you hear the
[__] things you hear kids getting hit
in the head with the [__] lights the
next year I went back and they had those
little half [__] helmets at that
time they were like little ones and
[__] but the circus was real at New York
City they didn't even have a net and
[__] at that time if a [__] lion if a
if a one of the guys fell off the top
you'd see the lion drag him off and [__]
oh my God it would help sweep him
off you know I started going to that
place when I was young I didn't know
what that place was and then as I got
older I got older and I was like Wow and
then when Michael Jackson came to town
in 1984 it was my equivalent of like Led
Zeppelin coming to town to shoot the
movie in 75 they just locked up New York
City it was just locked up Lee I can't
even describe what New York City was
like that day it was just locked up like
10 blocks around the garden you couldn't
move your [__] car people were just
jumping out of cabs and walking that's
that's how much intensity Michael
Jackson brought to that [__] Garden
not in 81 but an 84 I went to see him
both times and it's crazy not to derail
you but I just want to think about this
for like without the internet that
people went that crazy like was it just
in like the papers and like on the r
papers you
knew you you know New York City is a big
city very small City you know I like I
remember having friends that had friends
you know when I was like in the eth
grade that used to go to Keith Richards
and Mick Jagger's building in the city
so people start to find out your
Hangouts oh okay you know New York
City's big but but it's very small and
and we're all creatures of [__] habit
you know
so I don't even know what I was talking
about you were talking about the concert
you said it was it was like it was like
Michael Jackson in 84 Michael Jackson
but it's
like you didn't know but you knew so you
you had you know you you looked at where
the best hotel was in New York and
that's where you went looking for
Michael
Jackson some they allow kids and
giraffes I'm
saying
so it was like everybody was in New York
looking for Michael I still remember
Madonna Like Madonna crazy in New York
City like in 84 like I remember these
things and it was like so hard to
describe to people that's when you get
to see the real heartbeat that is New
York City like those are the like when
John lennin got shot that Monday Night
Football that following
Sunday the city was locked up the city
was so locked up I couldn't even get to
the park so in said I went to the
Village it's that type of [__]
atmosphere that type of energy let me
tell you something now we got there for
the doors opening and there were 30
people
online we cut the line we had clear they
got clear at the Garden so we whipped up
that old app out of the phone and we
just showed it we didn't even pay for it
we haven't had clear we cancelled it
like airplane fly what's that like the
air the clear from the airport they're
having at at Yankee Stadium they got a
bunch of places down oh that's smart
yeah you go to certain games cut the
line not get searched you know the whole
[__]
deal so you go you got right in got
right in and we were like the first ones
in our
area like I was like what happened to
this city and it was a lot of young
people but the the share was there and
that was interesting because the first
week bands were like kid bands you know
and the kids were dancing I went
downstairs and met with jelly roll then
I took my wife for the first band the
second band and went downstairs and saw
jelly roll and sat with him we talked
about the music the dog I congratulated
him and then we went back and the girls
were going crazy all of
them and there were these two old gay
guys all right New York City Gate see
again I'm not putting nobody down I'm
just talking about there's like four
generations of
gayism these are like the three the
third generation the guys my age maybe
67 okay that's a different type of gay
dude okay the you don't want to look at
them they because they'll suck they
they'll just look at you and you're
sucking their dick subconsciously like
that the Savages they mental Savages
they've been gay for 50 67 [__] years
they know how it's done they could crack
you know it's like nothing for them it's
like me showing up to an open mic for 10
minutes I could do it with my eyes
closed after 10 minutes I'm gonna have a
problem but these two dudes wouldn't
[__] smile to the first three [__]
bands okay I would sit there and just
watch him right I would just sit and I
gotta tell you more I would just sit
just to let you know things have not
changed in the Joey deer's world I'm
looking at these two gay dudes right
they're not even really good-looking
they're just old one of them is balding
the guy that was balding was the broad
because he had the purse right he had
like a little Macho purse so I'm
watching this whole thing go down
because I got a report back to Eric
right right so finally Shar came on
these guys were Furious the whole night
they kept looking at kids they couldn't
believe they were kids you know they
were just [__] miserable two gay
dudes that all are interested in was
[__] and [__] [__] like you could
tell when came on they got up out of
their seats they were jumping up and
down I God they were going [__] nuts
they had their phones out they were
hugging each other they were kissing
each other sang one [__] song 10
minutes right now these tickets I don't
know what they cost sh got off these two
guys got up and [__] abandoned [__]
that was it that's crazy not even a
smile on their faces after that they
went back to being miserable gay guys
from the 60s they got flashbacks they
got support groups of these [__] old
the [__] because nobody likes in the 60s
and 70s they didn't get to talk to
people till Madonna came out ' 85 they
saw some daylight so but then there was
one kid that was driving me [__]
crazy why three little chubby
girls I like just so people know you
know they were probably of the Jewish
descent happy Hanukkah right away I
don't like them because they're out on
[__] Hanukkah night right jumping up
and down but the thing that bothered me
the most was the kid the kid had to be
17 he was crying and yelling more than
the girls when people would perform to
the point where he was taking his phone
out and singing the lyrics to the phone
and he was Jewish skinny he had the hook
nose and he had the
Cur he had the curly [__] uh Ari hair
I couldn't take it no more so the one
girl sang a song called fruit cake and
I'm like fruit cake I'm calling him he
ain't answering me so finally I take a
piece of nicotine gum he's sitting there
looking at himself in between acts and I
just fling the nicotine gum no you
didn't come on now and it lands on his
shoulder he just looks at it he knows
he's getting hate mail and this just the
beginning
right so after once [__] uh jelly
roll came on he he wasn't into jelly
roll him and the chubby girls
but when Reza came
on the the sexy black girl which cashes
Morris said to me to slip her his number
because he wanted to bust into that
monkey right cash sent me a [__]
thing and she is very attractive that
girl Resa when Reza was on Riz whatever
her [__] name is I have no idea he
was dancing and yelling again ah like
you know I'm surprised those two [__]
didn't take him home like they should
just tapped him on the shower you want
to come to the other side follow us out
of here leave leave the three little
girls leave the candle take the condom
you know what I'm saying
leave take
condom why can't why can't Jews go out
on Hanah nothing you're not supposed to
stay in on Hanukkah you could go out on
Hanukkah but you can't be jumping up and
down like that like a [__] you know
you know and finally I took a piece of
gum and I just flung it and it bounced
over his shoulder went into his hair and
he flung it out and that was the end of
that after the show I just walked out
and I'm like I felt like grabbing him
going your cousins are fighting over
there now in a [__] hole against a
bunch of stink and death and missiles
and you're over here jumping up and down
singing like a [__] moo dor it just
burns me up Lee you know what I'm saying
I'm sorry I get emotional and that's
what if I saw anybody do acting like
that as a young kid I'd be like what the
[__] guy you're with three [__] girls
you're not even
boys you're with three girls ah yelling
like that come on it's got to stop this
cannot continue but I the whole 18,000
people the only people with testosterone
was the security guys everybody
else had no testosterone they had
slippers on whether they was six or 60
there wasn't a man in there I just took
my test a couple weeks ago and I got a
little high above average because I work
my legs and I you know I massage the nut
sack and keep it war and these guys
cannot deal with my test I I knocked my
wife up at 50 I'm slinging [__] I'll
whack off and throw the [__] against the
wall and it'll stick you know I'm still
slinging heat I'm [__] Cuban we're
primitive we we could some I can knock
somebody up at 80 just by flinging the
eyeball well you you talked about like
at going to concerts and like going with
like with Satan or the devil whatever
his name was what would you have done at
like 16 if you saw that kid dancing and
doing all that Stu it would have been
there was no police there was no videos
in those days that's when you light a
firecracker first you send them like a
little message B you always brought
firecrackers for those concs you brought
firecrackers always but I gotta be I
never lit one till like maybe I don't I
forget what G I finally lit one because
oh Azie at the Garden my friend was
getting dry humped right A friend of
mine didn't he sat next to a guy away
from us and the guy started dry and he
punched him Security is coming so that's
the first time but I did it after I saw
a bunch of people blowing off smoke
bombs in conscience in the New York New
Jersey area and I forgot about it and 30
years later I would listen to [__]
Jimmy Florentine on the radio and he
spoke about it but that was him I
[__] almost died when I heard the
story about he put a smoke bomb and the
security guard caught him and he had to
call his mom and he was stoned and his
mother him why you eyes so red you
know I love that you brought
firecrackers to a concert as a kid like
the small like I saw that [__]
firecracker screwdriver a bottle opener
you brought what you could all my
friends would bring those little wine
pouches that they'd hide I [__] hated
that [__] acting like Moses with a
little pouch [__] Jesus drinking wine
out of a [__] pouch at a continent
it's 90 [__] degrees out you got your
armpit on the [__] bottle I don't
want to say of that [__] and they would
pass it around like they were in the old
west get the [__] out of here it's 1980
I just saw you eating some chicks ass
the other night on 42nd Street and you
want to [__] share a glass with me
did you because I saw the uh the
Instagram you did with Mercy which was
great but you you didn't look like super
[__] up to go to this one or did you
did you
get I had kids with me right so I
couldn't go and [__] I I couldn't do
edibles
like I think I ate like maybe
200 balance out I ate one of those Fun
Fun Factory Farm cookies which is three
grams of mushroom and I didn't want to
bring a chocolate bar or nothing because
it would melt so I just
brought [__] uh I brought uh the
gummies the cherry flavored gummies
which is four grams I gave two of those
things away but I ate the other eight so
hold on so just to clarify a light night
for you is 300 milligram and about six
grams of mushrooms
yeah that seems
about listen I'm too old to go back to
the old church we all it just wouldn't
even fit into the [__] agenda I'm
living now but if I know I don't have
like tomorrow I got something at nine
and I got something at 10: and I got
something at 1 and something at two my
day is tremendous tomorrow IE a little
mushroom tonight I'm not going to lie
and I didn't even know no cookie and no
gummy I ate a mushroom cap oh that's a
you know what I don't that's the one
thing I really like about them you don't
really get hung over no like not even a
little bit tonight I'll eat a cap I'll
eat you know I put down a th000
milligrams I think I opened up with
eight and then I dropped another two out
of respect for [__]
Christmas and uh you know that's where I
am tonight I did a couple bits with some
new weed I got and that's where I am
right now this point in my life you know
I'm okay with that oh yeah I I just love
it like because I knew when you said you
didn't take Edibles I was like I think
satday Saturday night I had a shot of
something well I'm lying to you Friday
night I had a shot of uh tequila after
the jelly roll set you did yeah why not
you only walk on one leg I don't seen
shot oh this was a good shot too and let
me tell you something like I got I made
it back to the car I didn't feel it that
night I'm not gonna lie to you I didn't
feel it and from the adrenaline and
walking and stuff it probably just burnt
off I gotta be honest you like two
o'clock Saturday I was like I gotta I
feel a little hung over and I'm like
that's weird because I didn't drink I'm
like oh [__] that shot at tequila was
real that's crazy one shot at tequila it
didn't affect me at all no you felt a
little bit like you know I drank the
night before and then Saturday night I
went out with my buddies and for dessert
they passed out like [__] these
drinks that would just it would it
looked like peppermint snaps but it was
very
almondy I did one of those and I also
did a glass of sangria to open up the
dinner to get my appetite going because
I wasn't that hungry I like sangria red
sangria the red and the white at this
place ago and munaki nice was a real
what the problem was this weekend it was
very like I didn't go to the Garden
thinking that I was going to go through
that minute when I just sat there and I
realized how many times I had been in
there how lucky I was to I saw Michael
Jordan play there as a rookie against
Bernard
King you know I I just remember so many
things Michael Corin from Jersey City I
went to see him play at the Garden when
he played for North Carolina you know
the Sixers against the Knicks on
Christmas Day when my teacher got thrown
out out of there you know there's so
many memories I had to that place you
know I probably went to the metal lands
five times to watch a concert and I'm
probably exaggerating I saw Ted I saw
Michael Jackson out there in
84 maybe somebody else I never was out
there as much as I was at the Garden you
know and then Saturday I went out with
these dudes that you know since you know
I've known these guys since
74 75 I've known these
guys so that's 48 years you know just
knowing these guys and you look at them
and you see you you know these guys so
you look at them and you see them young
while you're talking to them and you see
what they' become you know and we got
there at 6 and we didn't leave till 10:
holy [__] that's a long time especially
for you dog it was that entertaining it
was that entertaining everybody was
talking [__] telling stories about cuz
remember out of the six guys that were
there four of us were in the same
seventh and eighth grade except one of
the guys transferred to downtown his
eighth grade
year and what made you have this dinner
I mean it sounds great but like you this
is not something you do we always we've
been getting together since I got back
here really yes I thought this was like
a holiday thing this was uh maybe the
fourth time in three years nice we've
gotten together we've been to Steakhouse
885 twice we've been to the other place
once we've been to we went somewhere
else in Red Bank and then this
place we go to this [__] we go to
steakhous 85 across street from the
stretch Factory that's a place with the
good burgers right like it's a crazy
thing to say but you said it was like a
great burger great but then around the
corner it's called the stage and that
motherfucker's got the burger and they
have Italian upstairs and it's a
steakhouse downstairs o upstairs and the
last time we were at Le they split a it
was like or six and we're sitting there
talking maybe seven of us and we told
the guy we go listen we all want steak
but we got to do the burger he goes that
happens all the time I'll bring you four
two burgers chopped in eights so it was
four pieces for a burger you got a
little of the burger you got a steak you
got spaghetti I mean these dinners are
heavy that's why I I had to drive 55
minutes so I couldn't take a thousand
milligrams that never stopped you before
so yeah but this is a new world so I
smok I smoked a little bit and once I
got there I couldn't smoke I couldn't go
into that restaurant smelling like reefa
I've been going there for 40 years you
know you don't think they know you don't
think you ever went in there smelling
like
weed well a very nice place us out 30
years ago they threw you out they didn't
throw us out they asked us to leave we
were too loud and they knew we were
doing blowing the bathroom and yelling
and scream and
so we brought it up the other night we
brought it up to them we were like hey
man remember 30 he like nah we the sun
we the son goes I'm 31 I go yeah when
you were a year old your dad threw us
out of here one night asked us he didn't
throw us out he just came home and he
goes guys what the
[__] that night it must have been 12 of
us holy [__] and he's like guys come on
you gotta go come on and and you were
what you were what and you're like late
20s early 30s I was
31 I come back here to do
comedy after I got divorced I came back
here but enough about me what happened
with you this weekend you were all
excited about a show on Sunday [__]
and some Chinese restaurant oh yeah I
had a I had a great comedy weekend like
I really I I a have gotten better about
reaching out to people I just reached
out to a a Booker who's been great and I
got I just randomly got a show on Friday
which was awesome okay um at a club that
I hadn't done and I I I called you
before because like I'm just really I
think I'm a pretty good I really do
think I'm doing pretty well as a feature
but as a host I'm struggling and I'm not
used to it so I called you for some
advice and all these open mics you go to
got a volunteer
host okay that's it just say I want a
host I'll be here all three hours 80
people you got exercise that night up
and down up and down gives you 80 shots
to try 80 lines or you know just kept
just volunteer hosting
yeah people always go away from what
they're not good at yeah is what you
want to do for a
living you gotta be good at because
somewhere along the line it may not be
today but nine years from now you'll be
in LA and they're going to call you to
do a walking hosting gig and you're
going to be kind of lost you're going to
be you you know it's going to take you a
while i' rather you [__] work that
the the thing I had that was lucky was
my first two years I had a hosting job
once a
week right and I still didn't know what
I was doing but then I started watching
uh Def Comedy chat okay I started
watching Joe Tor he's really good he was
good but the best host I ever saw
the guy who made me want to host was DL
hugley wow okay DL hugley hosted bet uh
uh whatever it was called on HBO one
night and he got a standing ovation from
the hosting holy
[__] that's powerful man and that made
me go whoa I get it now because while
you're hosting all you're thinking about
is getting to [__] the headliner spot
I want you to think about hosting and
and it's hosting as a living you're a
quarterback of a
team okay you're the one that controls
the tempo you control the co clock if
the [__] guy goes up and does 30 and
he's a magician and people falling
asleep I hope you didn't do your good
material the first five minutes because
now you gotta have to bring them [__]
back okay so on and so forth that was
actually a question that I like I ran
into it a couple of shows ago if I'm the
host I'm always worried about like they
don't want me to do time in between the
feature and the headliner just get the
headliner up there yeah I had a show a
couple they want we ain't listening
you're not gonna go up there and read
the Bible for [__] 15 minutes you're
gonna go up there and hit them with a
quick 28 second joke to get them back
but again you got 28 seconds who knows
how to do this you're looking at me you
and a bunch of comics that listen to
this are going what the [__] are you
talking about Joey exactly
if I say to you go up there and bring up
the feature let's keep it going for
[__] Joey Diaz he did great tonight
even though I ate a b bag of dicks right
right you saw he did great tonight look
at the audience and
go you did great tonight right whatever
the [__] you usually do and then you
just say something listen I'm gonna
bring up the headliner real quick let's
let's give him a round of applause he in
the way back there getting ready or
whatever don't even say Round of
Applause
and then hit him with something hit him
with something you on the news anybody
watch iwitness news tonight anybody see
the Mexican kid that got stuck in the
sewer boom that's it that was it you
condensed the whole bit into one [__]
line you don't have time to go in your
little green room or your little
computer and hit the click for jokey
poos this has to be constantly working
and that's what hosting does to you it
involves you in the [__] game when
you're a feature you're like my job is
to go up there blow out the headline
then go drink and meet broads not you
this makes you pay attention to what's
going on in the [__] game and then
when you evolve into movies and TV shows
when you become something and you get to
a trailer and they go to you Mr sayat
we'll bring you what you want you go no
no no no the first thing I want to do is
go on the set for an hour and see what's
going on I want to [__] feel the
tempo or the game same thing as hosting
you just took comedy and took it into
the next level and that's what every
step of Comedy is if you're thinking
about the next level it's the
prerequisite that you don't know about
you know like when you take college
algebra and they're like prerequisite
two and two is four Brea in a
glass they're prerequisites for
everything guys especially when you want
to do this as a [__] living now
am I going to tell you I knew I wanted
to do that listen when I was hosting I
could have been in jail any
day you know what I'm saying right up
to 2000 my comedy career was every time
I did a set you better do well because
you don't know if you're gonna be in
jail [__] something stupid drugs a fist
fight stole something you know I never
trusted myself and then when I made it
to 2000 I don't know why why I still
stole lighters from 7-Eleven but I was I
had a I had more lighters than 7-Eleven
from the one on
cson the football ones the football ones
I had every team except like three of
them they tried to rip me off [__]
bit but you know you
you you just you know when I was at the
store and I had the opportunity to
host I knew the previous hosts and what
they did with their careers
Freddy SoDo was about to hit you know
and the big host that hosted at the
store was the guy who died that he was
the host of America's Most
Wanted the co another host that The
Comedy Store had on Monday nights Dave
Letterman really yeah he hosted the
[__] Open Mic so I want the young
Comics to think about this [__] this is
something that takes you if you want to
do this as a career and you want to do
ex Dam hit every single aspect that you
could reach as your
career [__] you got to learn every
[__] position you know you know what
made Prince good what that he can play
every instrument on that [__]
out that's true and it's I'm not I'm not
I'm a little ashamed but it's honest I
did think about like this week I was
like if they ask me to host maybe I'll
ask them if I could just not
host like I it it I I hate when I don't
do well it [__] Burns me up yeah what
do you think I enjoyed it you think
anybody likes to bomb you think people
are like yeah Ma I'll eat the spaghetti
and then in an hour after I bomb I'll
come back and we'll play Monopoly I I
don't want to play Monopoly I want to
[__] shoot myself right more coke but
what you're not thinking about right now
after you bomb is that it's just a
number getting
closer to what you want to do as a as a
living it's it's it's like going up to
somebody trying to sell a [__] cell
phone and they say no and then the guy
next to you sells three of them and then
this guy sells them and you have a eight
day streak if you keep putting your
heart into it it's gonna turn and that's
the same thing with comedy you're gonna
go through dog you still even haven't
gone through that spell what oh no what
what spell you know there's a spell
Comics go through where they driving to
a gig in Rhode Island and they hit a
deer you haven't even gotten into that
venue yet oh I'm worried about that too
I have worried about what happens if I
get into an accident and I'm late for
the show then then [__] it then you're
late for the show you got into an
accident you hit a deer you'll see him
next time the gas you paid that comes
out of your pocket you learned the
lesson next time get a tank you know
what I'm
saying I [__] worry about everything
but I the uh the rest of the weekend was
great Sunday was honestly one of my
better days of Comedy being back in
Massachusetts because yeah I had a 1M
show at at a Chinese restaurant like an
hour outside of Boston and I was going
expecting no no one to be there and it
to be terrible and it was one of the
better shows I've done since I've been
back it was packed the woman who put it
together got a ton of people there they
were L to see comedy like the people
were fun the the crowd was cool and like
then I got Chinese food after it was
[__] awesome and it was just and it's
weird because I went from posting and
not doing great to literally at a
Chinese
restaurant with with Christmas
decorations up and I'm like I like they
they love I did great I had a great
show and then you went to see jezl neck
and that was
another yeah that was I've only seen him
it's crazy that I never saw him at the
store and I've seen his specials um but
I didn't really know much about him and
my cousins hit me up and just asked if I
wanted to go
and a and I'm sorry I think her name was
Kelly Ryan I think the feature she did
great but the only way I could describe
Jack because I've been thinking about it
today
was every joke he had a balloon and was
blowing it up and because like I could
feel like the audience like they were
just waiting for him to say something
[__] like they're just waiting for it
and then and then and like he sometimes
it takes a little longer and then when
he did it it would pop and the place
would go nuts like it was just so like
was I I don't want to say it's scripted
because I don't think it's necessarily
scripted but every joke is
so greatly written like there's not an
ounce of like an extra word
anywhere is it okay whatever he is it's
perfectionist brother you know he's very
funny very
dry very dark and what I respect about
jez neck the truth is anything he puts
on video is going to hit hit because he
puts two or three years into that
special yeah he doesn't pull what these
other guys are doing eight months and
there's another special and they're
talking about the same [__] the same way
a lot of comics do listen after 15 years
you got to run out of [__] material
so you got to keep it fresh you know
after you change so your point of view
changes you know everything changes so
you
cannot beat yourself up and even with
writing you're GNA have a period Le
where you're gonna write some bad
[__] jokes yep and then there's going
to be a period where you're gonna write
some great jokes and there's times I
tell you when it gets worse when you
don't know what's good or what's bad and
you put out like an album like eating
[__] with asthma that
album but again it was rushed we didn't
know in those days we thought the
material was good you know this is the
[__] you learn at the 20 year mark
so right now the best thing you could do
my friend is just keep getting on stage
if you if you bomb you get in the car
and you go to another Comedy Club yeah
it was jezel neck was so good that I
went to the the there's an open mic on
on Sundays in Wester and I went at like
10 o'clock because he was just he was so
good and it was crazy because he's not
super high energy and like I'm not and
then he also he did something that I've
seen that I've seen anyone do he [__] on
Boston like he basically said [__] you
never and people were like yeah like it
was like like no other comic could do
that like he was basically it was just
it's amazing what he's able to do he's a
gifted dude you know and uh he takes his
time it's it's a really good [__]
comedy show he's a compl you know now
you see the differences between him bur
two great great Comics just two
different [__] him and Chappelle you
know not there's a lot of great work out
there but you see who's putting in the
work and you see who's just shuffling
out material it become it becomes a cash
register I would do the same if Netflix
kept calling me every eight
months I'd be going on there singing
songs I'd have a band by now and a
[__] harmonica but real quick here's
to an ad from better help hey this
episode of the checkin is brought to you
by better help I love better help why
because I used them listen the holidays
are here we all get stressed out
sometimes you don't have to keep it to
yourself get online therapy with better
help whether you're working through
something really serious or you just
want somebody to talk to everybody needs
a friend and sometimes the cat don't
talk back to you if it does you got
problems for real but anyway better help
makes life easier and it's simple as
that that's it I love better help I was
with them for like a year it was
tremendous they gave me uh uh little
drills skills to cope with to learn me
you know how to control my anxiety and
here we are here we are that therapy is
completely online so you can meet with a
counselor whenever whatever works for
you you can meet with your therapist on
a video call on a phone call even a
message listen they even have two cans
with a string in the middle they'll get
you to help that you to get started take
a quick quiz on their
webs take a quick quiz on their website
and better help experts will match you
with a therapist if their first pick
isn't you you can switch at any time no
question asked do yourself a favor you
want to be giggling like me get better
help they help me I was for a year I
didn't know what was going on better
help is tremendous it's the season of
giving give yourself what you need with
better help trck me we all need a little
somebody to talk to visit betterhelp.com
Diaz di today to get 10% off your first
month that's betterhelp
hp.com Diaz betterhelp wants to offer
you a merry Chris and remember if they
talk back just run out of the room it's
over better help loves you we're back
all right don't forget for the holidays
it's rough this time of the year if you
need somebody talk to a shoulder to lean
on something contact betterhelp go to
betterhelp.com they're going to help you
out I know today I was talking on a
patreon podcast about I know this time
of the year this time of the year you're
jumping up and down or you [__] got
your dick in the dirt there's no in
between either you're broke and and
people have to learn one thing that some
of the best Christmases I had when I
when I was [__] dirt broke that's
when you saw what Christmas was about
the humanity you know people saying hey
Joey I know you smell you've been
sleeping on a rocket ship with piss but
come over wash your neck and you can eat
some turkey you know what I'm saying I
mean so I was talking about that so yeah
the holidays are [__] you know I mean
my agent called me today they close on
Friday oh yeah every it's dead right now
I was thinking about that today cuz I
have a friend who's looking for a job
and I told him I'm like listen don't
even bother right now like people are
check what if you go to any of these
department stores right now they'll hire
you for 10 days oh yeah like that kind
of a job yeah you don't have to be
[__] broke right now everybody's
looking for something you got a shovel
take down the Christmas decorations
there's going to be a parade in New York
City you could get two thou I don't know
what my friend was picking up there for
cleaning up the [__] sidewalk garbage
and sticks you know there's a bunch of
hustles now this is the time of year
that if you want work if you really want
work if you want somebody to give you 15
16 an hour go to a colds go to any of
those places you know they're stocking
dude I did it but when I when I got back
from La before I had a my day job I did
I only did it once but I still have the
app there's you can deliver Amazon
packages and they pay you like 2530 an
hour it's pretty I mean it's not like
consistent but you could if you have a
SUV you can deliver Amazon
packages in your area yeah and like I
did it once and it was it couldn't be it
took it took me like two hours instead
of the four hours they said it should
take because it was I got lucky and they
were all right next to each other
there's a lot of like it's pretty crazy
what you can do on your own schedule
like you're not going to get rich but
between like uber delivering [__] like
you can do a lot of [__] by yourself
with your phone I had a friend he's two
years younger than
me we grew up together I was just
talking to him about a week ago and he
told me that he got rid of his job he
didn't want to do it anymore he he
couldn't take seven more years there he
said he got an early retirement they're
not gonna start paying him till he's 62
and he's okay with that and he got a job
driving an Uber in an area where he's
putting down 250 a day the last couple
[__] weeks two weeks he's making
better money than if he had a job he's a
he's a [__] stalker like me he he
wakes up some nights at in the morning
to pee and he says he gets he stay
smokes a cigarette he go [__] it I get
my he goes I get my car at 4 to30 and in
five minutes I got a hit to go to nework
airport yeah oh yeah especially the
airport ones around there so he he goes
from all I know he don't live he lives
an hour from me but even like anywhere
like around like Newark or New York I I
had an Uber driver in Kansas City and I
thought about you because he broke it
down for me he's like I what I do is
when I take someone from the airport I
ask them if they if they're in town for
a conference and then I look up that
conference and I see what time the
things get out and if you like you can
definitely make money doing that that's
pretty cool and it it's nice because you
you have complete Freedom you can turn
it off whenever you want right now like
for people like I'm I'm a comic I can't
find any work I'm a musician I can't
right now is the best time to be a
comedian starting or a [__] musician
listen when I [__] started comedy I
had to [__] go into a an office and
sell insurance from 5 to 9 I had to you
found part-time jobs but you had it you
know for you to have your own car today
as a comedian like me if I was 30 if
this was
1993 and I really wanted to develop as a
comedian do as many sets as I could I
need to go to two places Austin Texas or
New York if you're spotless clean come
to New York they'll love you you'll be a
genius in the year because half the
clubs are very woke right I never
thought about that yeah it's not woke in
Jersey in uh Texas oh yeah and Austin
it's not woke they won't allow it you
know Rogan those guys like we're pushing
the [__] envelope we don't give a
[__] who's and right now you go to
Austin right now and as a fiveyear
comic you could borrow the money from
Grandma ask her Grant what Are You Gonna
Leave Me In The
Inheritance me a get an apartment you
know let me tell you something
apartments are not cheap in Austin so
you have to live outside of Austin
now but still driving in Uber to the
airport that Airport's packed off
[__] day people going down there
daily to look at houses homes to see
what the [__] mus is about they
already went to Nashville they've
already been to LA and got mugged by a
homeless guy it's time to go see what
Austin's about you know right and dog
thinking I mean I was thinking about the
other day I was in that limo and I was
talking talking to the guy and I go I
drove a limo and he goes how was it back
then and I go I I started at
4:30 and I I picked a box up at
Englewood clips and I would take it to
New York City Eyewitness News it was
like the news Clips or something I I
never looked in there and I would drop
it off and they paid me like $45 for
that run it was a quick $45 it was every
day and then from there I had the whole
I had that car and I in New York
City oh [__] the only thing that sucked
was
parking right that would have eaten up
that 45 bucks real quick real quick so
you had to drive around find the spot
and then I would run in and sign up for
an open mic that's how I learned all the
open mics by that [__] car I would
get myself two open mics it'd be 9:30
and I get a call to go to Kennedy
Airport twice go pick up this guy and
then go back in an hour and pick up
another guy perfect I just made a buck
50 for the night plus he's gonna tip me
so I would go up pick him up come back
what I'm trying to say is I had options
driving today you have more options
driving you got door Dash you got Uber
Eats you got Uber you got you know you
have all these ways as a young comic to
make a living and practice your [__] in
the car
you would that you would test it out on
people why not you're gonna get fighting
for a tip right right I guess and you're
not gonna you ever get in the car with
an Uber driver that don't speak your
language and the whole time he's got an
earphone on like [__] like he's Janet
Jackson's assistant
manager and three times while you're
driving with him in the [__] Uber you
actually look at him and go what he
ain't
talking he's talking to [__] Hamas
over there whatever the [__]
say think about now think about I got an
Uber driver maybe two years ago after
the pandemic I was going somewhere he
offered me a water he spoke to me he he
offered me candy there's candy in the
back there's hand sanitizer you know
what kind of music do you want this is a
[__] Uber X I'm a [__] fat [__] he
didn't know that he didn't know I was a
comedian nothing right at the end he
asked me he goes you look familiar I go
yeah and he goes oh I thought you one
the guys in The Sopranos but still the
guy offered you water there was candy
there was
sanitizer if you're just nice in this
[__] Uber business and you crack a
joke God forbid they smoke dope they
could picking somebody up at the
airport and you know they got no weed
and all a sudden you hit them with a
[__] number and you tell him to take
one to go what's that guy not going to
do for you Jesus Christ yeah you get a
lot of tips if you're giving away joints
as a tip as a bonusly you're giving away
your entertainment in comparison to what
you're going up against in New York
people not talking to you people at you
like you got three heads in a [__]
cab I need that oh I I can't it's a
whole different system in New York City
like you have to get like a taxi license
It's like because you can make money
money there but that's for like it's it
is pretty you got competition right the
probable LGE that you getting hit like
every three weeks you got to argue with
some guy who don't have insurance and he
don't know English and
[__] most likely [__] yeah that's so
that's what you would do now if you were
if you were 30s you'd do that it's just
it is pretty cool it's um do you
remember when you made the like the full
leap to not having like any sort of day
job how' be about 2002 when I
said you know I'm not making it
as a comic I'm not making enough money
as a
comic but I'm also not making enough
money doing whatever the [__] I'm doing
and I'm doing it together so after a
while if you're giving something else
50% of your energy I always sold stuff
so I'm
thinking and you're doing comedy and
look once I added the sales to the
comedy that's when everything
happen so you have to look at your
account your situation you have to plan
you know one thing I did as a comic in
the beginning was I didn't have much
money in 1990 when triple called me I
didn't have much
money and I remember that I looked at
what I brought in and I was honest with
myself my rent was 400 bucks Lee 28
years ago in Boulder you
know I didn't have a car payment I don't
know if I paid for insurance I doubt
it I put gas in the car I had a pay
I didn't go into this with a $3,000 or
$4,000
nut I knew this is bad
bones Jesus grandma gave you a th000 mom
gave you 500 this is bad bones your
uncle gave you a Nissan from 2008 with
150,000 miles you take care of that car
you got another 150,000 miles so all you
got to do is pay for insurance you put a
blanket in there you put everything you
think of in that [__] car blankets
can openers a basketball a frisbee
another blanket anything that you think
Band-Aids and you start doing
comedy if this is what you really want
to do you know think of the great Comics
what they did you think I wrote this
book on Comedy I remember hearing
stories about Mitch Hedberg and Char
Hogan getting in a car and going from
New York to LA doing guest sets and
clubs doing 30 guest sets in a week and
and getting eight weeks of
work wow you know not everybody had the
same path [__] Doug Stan hope won San
Francisco he was living in his car and
the day of the contest somebody broke
into his car and stole his clothes holy
[__] he went to a thrift store he bought
a suit and he went in there and won with
comedy you have to learn the other thing
that's in your way there's two things in
your way with comedy you and adversity
and
adversity because shit's gonna [__]
happen shit's gonna happen to throw you
off your game the universe takes care of
you in more ways than you'll ever
[__] know and when they throw a
little how about I got arrested in in
Idaho and I had a show at nine
o'clock and I got to the show at 10 at n
like nothing
happened I
don't I I I'm not trying to F did did
you hit someone with a a a a tray of
food like yeah you know is that
adversity I shoplifted a tent and I
tried to bring it back oh the T that was
where the tent was okay I was trying to
think what Idaho was it's [__] that is
[__] up though that you'll get so
after that I'm like I can't trust myself
to [__] not be in jail one of these
days in one of these towns what happens
if you pull out you got a gr a Coke and
the person who's driving is drinking I'm
going to jail so right you have all this
adversity in front of you and then you
have your own
demons but with comedy the demons got
nothing to do with you if you still
right and push forward if you let the
demons get you I mean listen the demons
will get you after a while the demons
will always get you if you let him but
for me the demons went away the more I
progressed in comedy do you know what
I'm saying like they started going away
started going away and you're always
going to have two or three of them in
there but you learned to cope with them
you open up the closet once a month you
go
hello it's
it's to get humbled like
it's it's kind of scary for me right now
in a way in a good way like I'm it's
exciting but like I look at all the
comics that I got to meet and that I
like and then I look at like some that I
meet either featuring or at other shows
and they're very
funny but they didn't they're not
touring the not at that level is the
level that I want to be at and it's just
like what did they do wrong or or what
did they what did these other people do
right like it just it's a it's a big
tossup if I'm
ever gonna quote unquote make it I know
that can change for anyone but that's
like to even be a working comedian is a
big tossup what people don't understand
is that when you're getting to that
feature act when you're getting to that
beginning to get in there you're feeling
good about yourself s but you're getting
a lot of negative feedback from younger
Comics that they blame the world for
everything there's people who just blame
the world for everything they did this
to me he didn't like me so you're G to
go in there one day and go this weekend
I'm working for Joey de he's got a club
in Boston and some guy's gonna go [__]
that dude I went in there and killed he
never brought me back now you've known
this guy for three months he's never
Gotta Laugh right you following me yeah
so you're GNA have a lot of negativity I
mean for me in the beginning it's just
different clubs and what people will
tell you but while they're telling you
all the negativity all you're thinking
about is the sets I'm gonna do five
sets in F in three nights I'm gonna make
$400 and I'll live with that no matter
what this guy is telling you I've been
through way worse right and then after I
became a feature and I started
headlining and touring the West Coast oh
my God
Lee I mean 60% of the comics I work with
destroyed La you're never GNA make it
don't even try it I've been there for
eight years I never got a spot at the
Improv yet I go every Sunday I put my
name in the Hat but then you see these
guys and you see how they you know
they're tearing that oh you gotta be gay
to be in Hollywood and you want to smack
him in the mouth what are you talking
about I'm the opposite of [__] gay
and I love it I'm trying to get ahead so
I got to love it there it's a land the
opportunity for me but if somebody came
on to you and you suck their dick and
didn't get the pay off that ain't my
problem you bumped into the wrong Harvey
Weinstein
yeah that's so then you get into all
that negativity there's always gonna be
so much negativity and and that's tied
with mental
health so as they're telling you all
this bad [__] you're looking at them
going I'm sleeping in my car
buddy I live in my car I ate a Subway
for lunch and dinner and you're trying
to tell me that this guy [__] you I'm
gonna do it better than you did you went
in there unprepared you started drinking
at the bar you thought you were [__]
Johnny gambo I'm I'm not doing that I'm
going in there as a professional and
that's the problems that you have you're
gonna run into every time you say
something I'm going to Austin to do
Rogan's room well [__] him man I did
Kill Tony and I didn't get my deal from
CBS oh okay right okay it's uh I'm it's
just crazy it's uh it was a cool week I
I feel like I learned a lot this
week it's funny I gotta tell I think I
told you the other day
that jelly roll I mean the when when sh
went up two of the moms were crying and
the gay dudes are
crying I didn't say nothing you know
some times people move you to tears
sometimes I know I get moved to tears a
lot when jelly roll came up and he was
singing uh need a favor you know I tell
you man I got emotional and also I'm
like you know what you know what's crazy
about me I got unfinished
business you know I go if I start
getting on stage this
month maybe I could start touring again
and maybe next year I could sell this
[__] Garden out
I really thought about that and when I
went down to see jelly I told him I go
you inspired me a little bit brother
that was [__] great because I know
where you came from you know you really
get to know
people I got home put ice on my knee put
ice on my ankle went to bed went to a
kids basketball game I came in here I go
all right let's write some jokes like
[__] that
[__] you know I got Mo he inspired me
for a couple minutes and I think it's CU
I know know how much working is
involved and I just don't have 10 hours
a day to become a great comic again I
wish I did I take naps in the afternoon
now I'm up at 6:00 am 5: am you
know because I know how much work goes
into this
process and you and
I I'm the type of guy that I like to
check on people from time to time right
and what they're doing
and I check on the people that were the
complainers really yeah I check on the
people
who said negative things like at the
comedy store at The Improv
or and these guys could have kept their
mouth
shut if they would have kept that even a
guy like me I'm a [__] criminal and I
kept it together at the store and I kept
it together at The Improv and I kept it
together at the Laugh Factory
and then for many years I went to
theaters and clubs not a [__]
complaint you
know but it's
uh it's just crazy that these guys go
into these places and they think they're
[__] Belushi and then they want to
come back like listen there's a people a
lot of people from the old days didn't
re me no matter how many tickets I was
selling but it was very
interesting to see and these guys were
always complaining in La about something
and you check on what they're doing now
and they're still doing backyard comedy
shows they're still they're living in
pong towns doing like these shows that
you're like so you complained about all
that to go back to
this right yeah there's a lot of that
and I feel really bad because they just
didn't wait for the miracle to
happen and listen you can't go from
being a waiter and doing spots at
Vinnie's Landing in
LA to you know it's not going to happen
that way I never saw
it I never saw it I mean we have a new
process now you know for years people
became YouTube stars now we got Tik Tock
Stars you know and uh I'm always happy
when somebody makes it especially when
somebody tricks their way in I tricked
my way in Kim kadashian tricked their
way in when you really look at
successful people they trick their way
in you know but then at some point you
have to cover the spread so you trick
their way
in now what can you now what are you
gonna do it's like I tell people so you
got the Johnny Carson you got a [__]
spot on Johnny
Carson you're only thinking about the
spot I'm thinking about I know I'm gonna
destroy the [__] show what's your
next move you always have as a comic you
gotta be looking at that little move not
the garden
don't come to me when you're still
sending out tapes you know you can't get
and say you know I see the Garden in my
future shut the [__] up I want you to
worry about the thing in front of you
you know for me it was always like the
improvs The Comedy Store was always
seemed so far away when I first started
comedy but the improvs had 22 clubs at
the time maybe eight of them I knew that
one of them would take me you know what
I'm saying is this all from sales like
like looking ahead like your next focus
on your next goal like that was what you
just said was pretty big to me like f
like what like what you're gonna it's
about [__]
life comedy is down and [__] dirty
it's about life like anything else and
you're always trying to break in but
you're breaking in but always thinking
about after you break in what are you
gonna do when you get there what good is
it if I could break into a bank if I
can't open up a safe what am I going to
do wait outside the door
wait God to open up the
safe right my brain doesn't think like
that I guess and it just like it makes
total sense and I I need to start
thinking like that and I you do a little
bit it's not your fault that you don't
think that way it's not your fault
you're
not you're still putting the pieces
together I don't expect you to think
that way I should expect
you I expect you to know I think that
way because I saw it happen in front of
my
eyes I saw Chelsea happen Chelsea
Handler she was opening for a tell got
on the show you know playing pranks
there there it
is I saw Josh Wolf take off in front of
my eyes I saw Ralphie May blow up on
Last Comic Standing you know you heard
all the stories I saw Joe Rogan go from
news radio to Fear Factor to so I I want
people to know there's always
possibilities if you do the work but
most important I saw myself do
it I would think about things and go
yeah maybe and then we're halfway there
well I always knew I was going to get
here because I kept doing my job but
silently I was actually going for that
thing I just didn't tell you it's none
of your business what I'm going for it's
my thing I don't need Lego and whatever
happened with The Longest Yard [__]
you lost it to that fat [__] this is my
thing and I'm gonna work on it as hard
as I can to get that I think the comics
take a lot of bad chances in La you saw
it what about the guy who shot the
special and then it was going to go on
Showtime his friend and then he went to
put it up and there was an air
conditioner behind him that kept making
noise and nobody could hear the audience
laugh everybody thought they were going
to beat the
system shooting my own specials and
doing this it's time to shoot your own
special somebody will let you [__]
know and then you can put it on YouTube
and not worry about stuff you know but
that's what I saw I saw a lot of people
working hard but not working
smart I saw rafie go from a [__]
one-bedroom AP apartment to a mansion up
on the
hill I saw these
things I saw myself going from a
one-bedroom apartment with nine cats to
a house in New
Jersey and the ability to pay for it and
years of doing standup and you know did
you you thought when I first started
doing comedy theaters were in my I was
thinking about
theaters what let me ask you this at my
level at five years what was your dream
did you have a comedy dream my dream was
to go on
tour my dream was to do a
tour just to get in the car and
drive and get the [__] away from who I
was and everything involved with it and
just drive from City to City smoke
different pot ate different and try to
make people laugh at the fiveyear Mark
there was never a thought of anything
else guys I st remember going to
Michigan and meeting a girl and we end
up going to Seattle do you think that
was in my plan and then I go to Seattle
and the first kid I meet is Josh
Wolf you think that was in my plan you
know and I met Josh Wolf in a pool of 48
Comics 50 Comics out of those 50 Comics
three of them came
down and could you see that in Josh like
like could you is that what attracted
you to him or was just him personally it
happen to be you too I just knew he was
a hustler and a winner you know I knew
Josh and he was really good-look and I
knew that what he was going for I
watched him on stage we we both ate the
same nachos on a Tuesday night when we
were
broke you know when you see that it
tastes a lot better so what I want to
tell Comics is what I tell the thing
that pissed me off the most about my
high school was my guidance
counselor because didn't tell me about
New York City and all the opportunities
I had there nobody ever told me about an
acting class in New York City my
freshman year I won the [__] improv
thing you know I took intro to
performing arts and one of them was
improv and I went up there and I sang
like shatter and I W first place nobody
pulled me aside and said have you
considered going into the
city wow yeah that wasn't really
considered back then and nobody consider
nobody showed me the app
opportunities so my mind was always
closed to dog you could you know for
years I thought oh I'll be in the city
bartending and Bruce Willis will come
in and hire me for a
movie that's like a stupid kid dream
that's like a pipe dream right does it
happen from time to time I'm a producer
I come into a movie The into a bar we
get hammered you get me a gramar coke I
I need a waiter for this movie
I'll give you the part for scale for two
days well like now that would be luck
but back then it sounds like you didn't
even like know that there were other
ways to do it no and it wasn't until I
was ready listen I never thought I would
go to La knock on wood and God bless
Doug Stan hope for talking me into La I
remember going this is it Doug Stan Hope
was walking me into the lion that I'm
gonna die I'm G to get eaten alive up in
La I ain't a [__] comic for LA but DG
I hit the floor
running because I knew I wasn't the
comic for La so now I had to work myself
up to being that comic you know a year
ago I got a blue
belt was I a blue belt at the time [__]
no but he gave me a blue belt after I
was there for a year and a half and over
this year beside the injuries I've grown
into being a okay blue belt I could
sweep I could Mount I could do different
things am I a blue belt with eight
Stripes am I a purple belt [__] no my
point
is when I got into the store I wasn't
ready but just walking in that door and
doing those sets got me
ready you know there's a thousand
stories about like baseball where a kid
gets called up for the World Series and
he ends up hitting three home runs
people are like he's not ready but after
a game he'll be [__] ready
you know I never thought you were ready
for this [__] and you were you sat there
listening and you sat to and like I've
told you a thousand times before the
common
denominator was always the guys who kept
pushing and hard work they didn't give a
[__] what you had to say and they had
listen having good people around you
helps
absolutely if you know when those kids
bother you and go hey man how about me
you Lee and [__] uh we go to Boston
we get all the big comics and we make a
movie that movie will do a million
dollars what are you talking about
stupid I'm
definitely meanwhile you're mind [__]
yourself with a stupid movie right you
could be writing a joke this is just
about writing jokes and getting on stage
that's it I don't want to hear your
nonsense when I when it's time to hear
your nonsense I'll [__] call you
until then the only thing I want to hear
from you is month ly 32 sets 48 sets 52
sets and I bombed 55 of those sets you
know I don't care because I know the
more you get on stage you're gonna twist
the the [__] odds we've had these
conversations lately oh yeah and it's
with it's with anything you know right
now I'm outlining a book did you know I
didn't know when I met you I didn't know
how to outline a
book no you were bar you were doing the
blog I couldn't yeah and that was a
[__] nightmare of a Blog the spelling
was
wrong oh but now I could write a blog
I'm just lazy I won't I thought about
it I just don't know what I'd write a
blog a [__] about you know so am I
gonna Force the hand like a [__] M
theore hell no but it it I love these
talks man they mean a lot to me because
it's no I love them too because I want
to get this [__] out there for people
because the one thing that bother me the
most of the last five years living in La
was the hit and
Runners and you and I will not going to
drop names we had a hundred hidden
Runners we had people who thought we
were gonna save
them okay got me mad because I wasn't I
couldn't save you if you saved yourself
a little bit then I could help you you
just wanted to [__] bust in walk in
and Doug I saw that my last 10 years
more than any time I was was there
before how many people were really just
trying to piggyback
and you know dog how many people laughed
at me when I started doing podcasting
with Felicia Michaels I still remember
being at a [__] barbecue I'm not
gonna tell you who is like dog you're
wasting your
time meanwhile this poor guy right now
is a no folks home
somewhere you
know yeah that's awesome that you get to
do that it's it's really weird what the
people really don't know what they have
inside them and I hope from this podcast
especially tonight they learn that
there's more in them than they [__]
really know because if you thought when
I was in that jail cell I saw myself on
the set with David Chase whether it was
a good movie or a bad movie you're out
of your [__]
mind you
know when I walked on certain movies
when I walked on uh the dairo movie I
knew exactly what I was doing as an
actor forget the standup I knew exactly
what I was doing 2013 I had been acting
for [__] 15 years at that time I knew
exactly where to sit where to stand that
means I save
time you know I say I go prepared but I
learned all that from
standup
[__] it's it's it's amazing how much I
have like left to learn
that's it's intimidating but the
learning nobody could teach you that's a
problem with standup nobody can teach
you what you learn is by going out
there by putting yourself out there
right now your next move is to contact
and I told you this as many one nighters
as you can in the five state
area somebody's got to have a name of a
[__] Booker who's got three rooms in
Vermont a Wednesday Thursday and a
Friday that you know he gives you a ski
pass he buys you two mugs of beer and he
puts you
up but if you really want to do comedy
you're thinking about 10 years from
now and even you think of 95 I was
thinking about 10 years from now just
put me in jail now for felony liing I
never thought about that because in 95 I
was 10 years away from The Longest Yard
coming out
do you really think I saw that
coming the [__] out of my face but I I
mean you didn't have the resources that
I have so hopefully I can use it I I'm
trying I just knew I had to get
standup and I would get funnier I
couldn't afford acting class in
1995 but I knew that Robin Williams had
impeccable timing from standup and I
knew there was a lot of other ICS that
had become great actors and rappers so
we always had a chance but that's in the
back burner let's get to be the the
thing that matters the most the funniest
[__] that we could be I'm
watching Star V is special tonight oh it
was good yeah I heard it's really good
so I'm gonna give him a shot and that's
it Le two weeks away from
Christmas next Monday we'll be on and
then we'll figure one podcast in before
for New Year's because New Year's Day is
a Monday but maybe we do New Year's Day
I don't know let's see what the [__]
cracking in the world of podcasting
we'll figure it out I can't wait figure
it out well I'm happy about tonight I'm
happy about your Sunday it seemed like
you had a great Sunday last week it was
great and uh it's time to go watch
[__] starvos the special eat a
[__] cheeseburger with no bread and
[__] smoke a few numbers and see what
happens with these Edibles tonight this
m room I love you but I'll be at I'll be
at Mohan Sun this this Thursday through
Saturday with Josh Wolf if you're in
holy [__] congratulations my brother
that'll be a call me when you're on the
M well I'll talk to you after this in an
hour probably yeah I'll definitely call
you on Friday night all right let's do
this have a great [__] uh week and
now for a word for my [__]
sponsors
Jack
[Music]
the freeze pipe you need a little
something to get you through the holiday
family reunions we all do freeze pipe
wants you to smoke and save big with
their holiday sales that are running now
until Christmas this is where you get
Grandma present the neighborhood cop the
delivery guy get them all little bongs
perfect for anybody who's tired of harsh
smoke and coughing all the time freeze
pipe makes freezable pipes bubblers
bongs more than cool down Smoke by over
300° me I love freeze pipe guys right
now I'm smoking like one of the many
bongs that they sent me and I love it
all you got to do is put the glycerin
chamber in the freezer for an hour and
when you're ready to get down pull it
out put it in take a hit of that bong
and boom nothing but icy clouds the hell
with Snoop Dog you could even keep the
glycerin chamber in the freezer the
whole time you'll never have to wait so
do yourself a favor right now you're
scratching your head what do I get this
guy what do I freeze pipe that's what
you're gonna get them so go to the
freeze pipe.com pressing code Diaz di
for 10% off your entire order who's
better than freeze pipe nobody that's
right shop holiday sales running until
Christmas or use code Diaz for 10% off
at the free pipe.com order today and
smoke like royalty you know what I'm
saying I don't know what the hell that
means the the line is smoked like a
doctor you [__] anyway the joint is also
brought to you by manscape listen men
ladies you got to shave that [__]
Mona you want Santa to come he can't
come over and you got a bush that looks
like a [__] jungle this isn't about
looking hot for a partner this is about
giving yourself the Christmas gift of
silky SM balls with manscape the new
performance 5.0 package this
[__] is a Savage the lawn more
5.0 has got the old the ultra body
trimmer forget about your ball fact you
can shave your eyebrows your nose hairs
the hairs in your [__] with a fishing
wire it's tremendous it also has the
weed whacker the nose hair trimmer and
the crop so the aftershave lotion and
the best one of them all the crop
preserver boil deodorant it takes the
wrinkles out of your nut sack looks like
a baby's elbow anyway you got to love
[__] manscape when you get the
performance package 5.0 manscape will
even throw in two gifts a super
comfortable pair of boxes and a bag to
store your goodies in with a zipper
inside I ain't saying nothing whether
you're buying it for yourself or for
someone you love for Christmas I got a
discount code for you you ready get 20%
off free shipping with code Joey at
manscape.com who does that for you no
nobody [__] that's 20% off with
free shipping at manscape.com use code
Joey manscape wants you to have a happy
holidays and here we go for you
[__] who want to be
International the year is almost over I
know you want to make uh you know
resolutions you want to learn new
language in three weeks you got to use
my people Babble that they know all the
languages those other language learning
apps forget about it they're just basic
games that teach you nothing Babel will
get you talking to the Mexican waiter
you're talking to the guy that throws
knives at Benny forget about
it bab will get you learning with 10
minute lessons you'll be taught
everything you need to have to work to
be a world you know you could converse
with anybody let's say you going to a
strip club you want to learn Russian bam
there you go listen I love Babel reminds
me of my old school Spanish it's easy
it's fun and you look look smart and
what else could you want studies even
show that you Z Babble for 15 hours is
just like taking an entire semester of a
college language course so aren't you
sick and tired of the Mexican way to not
talking to you no more you want to call
him over seor that's it where you gonna
learn that Babble and here's a special
limited time deal from the check-in
listeners to get you started for the
holidays I'm going to give you 55% off
but only for checkin listeners for Babel
Joey that's Joe y That's 55% off at
babel.com
joeey spell Babel B- a BB L they're even
going to teach you how to spell Babel in
German or Romanian or something like
that so babel.com
joeey rules and restrictions May apply
Merry Christmas